you're watching the daily climate show
on Sky News coming up on today's program
prioritizing the economy over the
environment after climate pledges are
sacrificed to secure a trade deal with
Australia Sky News learns future deals
could follow suit
carbon emissions from the world's
richest nations are back on the rise
with some already exceeding pre-pandemic
levels
standing down insulate Britain tells
Boris Johnson they're suspending their
protests until later this month
and brought down to earth Prince William
criticizes billionaire space tourists
advising them to help fix the planet
first
[Music]
hello and welcome to the UK's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions now there was outrage amongst
climate campaigners last month when our
Deputy political editor Sam codes broke
the news that ministers had bowed to
pressure and dropped binding commitments
to the Paris global warming agreement
from the UK's trade deal with Australia
well today Sam has seen evidence that it
might not be a one-off contrary to the
message being delivered to the public a
leaked document from the Department for
international trade suggests deals
should prioritize economic growth over
Environmental Protections in other trade
agreements too here's Sam's report
lecturing the world just weeks ago our
prime minister telling the United
Nations they must do more when it comes
to the environment it's time for
Humanity to grow up the Glasgow cop 26
Summit is the turning point we need all
countries every single one of you
to step up but what about when it comes
to our trade deals with the rest of the
world
an internal document from the Department
for international trade leaked to Sky
News and then retyped by us was sent
across Whitehall Department it said HMG
that Her Majesty's government should not
refuse to liberalize on products of
environmental concern where there is an
economic case for liberalization or
partner interest is so strong that not
doing so would compromise The Wider
agreement
that means lowering standards or
liberalizing to boost the economy or get
the deals over the line labor says the
government has got its priorities wrong
it's really shocking to see a document
going around government where they're
essentially saying look
never mind about climate change never
mind about the environment
bolsonaro is a difficult guy if we want
to have a trade deal with Brazil and he
wants to sell us stuff from the
rainforest we probably shouldn't get in
the way that much because otherwise we
won't end up with a trade deal well
really the trade Department says this
does not represent official government
policy but senior Tories are worried by
the lack of green goals the government
has already committed to a whole host of
projects in developing countries to
encourage free forestation we shouldn't
at the same time be allowing other
forests to be chopped down to produce
goods and and agricultural products to a
lesser standard than we are ourselves we
have to have joined up policy making
across government
yeah
that was the question asked when Sky
News revealed that climate change
targets had been dropped from the
Australian trade deal signed with this
man over the summer the
can leak obtained by Sky News raising
doubts about the government's commitment
to climate change in trade deals the
government responds broadly by shouting
fake news but given that there's concern
on all sides wouldn't they be better off
explaining that trade deals mean big
trade-offs I don't think it is a
surprise that the UK government is
prioritizing uh trade deals and the
economy over climate change I think the
surprise is that they feel they need to
do it so much they don't feel they can
bring together trade deals the economy
and climate change palm oil from
rainforests like this is currently
banned but could be allowed into the UK
in future under this approach we're
talking about products which are
responsible for the decline in our
rainforest for pollution in our oceans
and the huge impacts of climate change
and those are the kind of things we
should really be ruling out of trade
deals not rolling in maybe Boris Johnson
has no choice but to lower standards if
he wants trade deals but he doesn't like
discussing trade-offs in public leaving
others to point the finger Sam Coates
Sky News
carbon emissions from the world's
richest 20 Nations have increased
dramatically during the course of the
Year according to the annual carbon
transparency report it found that the
G20 are responsible for 75 of global
greenhouse gas emissions and that CO2
emissions are expected to increase by as
much as four percent
across the group of Nations this year
now that's after they fell six percent
last year due to a drop in demand
because of the global pandemic the
report also says that coal use across
the G20 is projected to rise by 5 this
year as the global economic recovery
results in increasing demand for energy
now China alone is responsible for
around 60 percent of that increase in
Coal use and is expected to exceed its
pre-pandemic 2019 emission levels this
year as are India Indonesia and
Argentina
now Prince Charles says urged the
world's financial institutions to come
together and invest in climate Solutions
he was speaking within the past hour at
a world Bank event in Washington called
making climate action count turning
ambition into reality
we need to align industry investment and
Country transition road maps
to build pipelines of investable and
genuinely sustainable projects
multilateral development banks have a
critical role to play to help build
technical capacity mitigate risk and
improve the flow of private Finance
particularly in the world's most climate
vulnerable countries
well elsewhere in Washington the White
House confirmed today that President
Biden will definitely attend glasgow's
cop 26 Summit in person let's bring in
Skies Sally Lockwood who's in Washington
today and suddenly so many climate
developments coming out of there
meanwhile climate protests us becoming
quite a familiar sight in the city so
what are they asking for
they are calling for more action against
the use of fossil fuels they've been
staging protests every day in Washington
this week and certainly they welcome the
news today that President Biden has now
announced he will be attending Glasgow
at the end of the month but they want
more action of course since President
Biden came to power we have seen many
promises when it comes to his intentions
on climate change rejoining the Paris
agreement setting ambitious targets when
it comes to cutting greenhouse gases and
looking to steer the country towards
more use of electric cars but certainly
there is a sense of skepticism here in
Washington about just what can be
achieved in Glasgow not all countries
have the right Energy Mix to meet that
1.5 degree Target and on top of that
they also know that John Kerry's talks
with China hasn't exactly resulted in
much when it comes to any public
promises for them to cut their emissions
faster either of course China Remains
the greatest polluter on the planet and
their commitments are needed but
certainly America has closer problems at
home domestically when it comes to
passing significant legislation on
climate change with a tiny Democratic
majority in Congress some have said that
should they fail to pass significant
legislation here in the states it could
be a serious and as detrimental as
Donald Trump pulling out of the Paris
agreement all over again
Sally thank you
well demonstrations may be continuing in
Washington there but after five weeks of
protests insulate Britain says it's
suspending further campaigns until the
25th of October the climate change
activists have blocked roads causing
major disruption to motorways and routes
around London including the M25 they've
been demanding the government take
meaningful action to insulate the UK's
homes
there's a warning that burning biomass
will push the government's climate
targets further off track a report by
Chatham House and woodwell climate
Research Center says treating the
burning of Woody biomass as green fuel
masks the emissions from the Harvest of
live trees and the decay of roots left
in the forest wood pellets produced in
the U.S and burnt in the UK were
responsible for 13 to 16 million tons of
CO2 emissions in 2019 alone the biomass
industry currently receives tens of
millions of pounds in government
subsidies
conservationists are on the hunt for
citizen scientists to spot walruses in
pictures taken from space scientists are
hoping to find out how many walruses
live in the Arctic by recruiting members
of the public to look through thousands
of high-resolution satellite images and
Report any sightings to WWF and the
British Antarctic Survey it's hoped that
half a million people worldwide will
join the walrus from space research
project
now there was much excitement yesterday
when Jeff Bezos took the Captain Kirk
actor William Shatner closer to space
than he'd ever been before but today the
Amazon and blue origin founder was
seemingly rebuked by Prince William who
suggested that billionaires should
concentrate on saving the Earth rather
than space tourism our science
correspondents Thomas Moore reports
foreign
the new age of space tourism has been
another giant leap for greenhouse gas
pollution even the water vapor released
by William Shatner's ride with blue
origin can result in global warming when
it's released into the upper atmosphere
Virgin Galactic and soon SpaceX release
huge amounts of carbon dioxide to all to
give the privileged few a taste of
weightlessness and a spectacular view of
the planet it's an indictment on the
efforts we're trying to make and he sort
of it undermines us making sacrifices
here on on Earth to make sure that we
mitigate the impact that we're having on
the environment and then Rich
billionaires are flying out into space
for very expensive selfies
a long-haul Air flight typically emits
between one and three tons of carbon per
passenger a rocket launch can result in
between 200 and 300 tons of carbon
dioxide or 50 to 75 tons per astronaut
but as well as carbon dioxide there are
[ __ ] particles chemicals and other
polluting gases released into the upper
atmosphere where they do more damage
they not only trap heat but they trigger
a chain reaction that ultimately
depletes the ozone layer a protective
shield against UV radiation
not all space missions are equal You
could argue tourism is a little
frivolous but the new space age has
brought us a better understanding of our
perilous position on Earth
there's the image of our tiny Blue
Marble that gave liftoff to the
environmental movement many more showing
the astonishingly thin band of the
atmosphere protecting us from the void
of space and the observations of
shrinking Arctic Ice that have rung
alarm Bells there's this notion called
the overview effect where people who fly
at high altitudes or see the Earth from
space really have a sort of changed
moment in their lives where you see the
fragility of Earth hanging in the
Blackness of space and as we start to
see more regular like folks going to
space and experiencing this that it
really has the chance to increase our
environmental Consciousness
within the next few months SpaceX is due
to take private astronauts into orbit
needing even more rocket fuel to break
free of gravity these are early days for
the space tourism industry but Virgin
Galactic alone is aiming for 400 flights
a year the carbon footprint of
billionaires taking the ultimate
sightseeing trip is about to go
stratospheric Thomas More Sky News
do you say with us coming up after the
break I'll be joined by Professor Dame
Julia King the chair of the carbon trust
and Kel Spellman actor and WWF
Ambassador and we're going to be
discussing how much of a role space
exploration has to play in finding
climate Solutions and whether Britain is
putting trade deals ahead of climate
goals that's all coming up
[Music]
I'm Greg Milam Sky's U.S correspondent
here in Los Angeles
can you go away we take you to the heart
of stories that shape our world
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
so there are hundreds of these turbines
but thousands more across Gansu
Family Guy
that's what's left of the north tunnel
where the North Koreans exploded five
nuclear warheads
[Music]
this is a show of strength at a time
when China is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
from that explosion I think you can see
it littered along all the way we take
you to the heart of the stories that
shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports that they are
being blocked by police so we're going
to try and find a way out of Wuhan
after five days of stranded here this is
deliverance we help you understand the
world with us
Tom Cheshire Sky News Beijing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs Turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the Daily
climate show on Sky News now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
Professor Dame Julia King baroness Brown
of Cambridge who was chair of the carbon
trust and also the actor and WWF
Ambassador Kel Spellman so good to see
though thanks for joining us tonight
so first of all economic growth should
be prioritized over Environmental
Protections in future trade deals that's
the line emerging from a leaked document
seen by our Deputy political editor as
we heard at the top of the pro program
Julia to you first of all on this the
government says nothing to see here they
say this isn't government policy they
say it's not been considered by
ministers but what's your reaction to
this leaked Memo from civil servants
I I think it's very worrying indeed I
mean we've seen already the removal of
the Paris commitment of one point aiming
for 1.5 degrees from the Australia trade
deal we should be using trade deals to
uh to encourage others and to pressurize
other countries to sign up and deliver
on these critical
um Paris and Net Zero commitments and we
should also be using them to make sure
we're protecting our own Industries
um because we're expecting these very
high environmental standards rightly and
also expecting our own Industries to be
on track for Net Zero we shouldn't be
importing Goods where people haven't had
to to meet those standards and indeed
meet those sorts of costs Kel what do
you think of this let me just show you
what the Australian prime minister Scott
Morrison said he said in trade
agreements ideal with trade issues and
climate agreements I deal with climate
issues I mean some people might say the
main main priority here is the economy
post-brexit post covet and any climate
agreements can be made separately
uh I'd have to push back on that for me
because I think the more we're learning
actually that all these different areas
of conversation and deals are actually
all intrinsically linked with climate
and I think if we're starting to
separate a trade deal and climate deal
uh it's actually quite ignorant because
you know climate affects trade and
climate affects money and climate
affects movement of goods and climate
affects everything so to actually
approach them as two very separate
things for me makes no sense and
actually as I think what was written in
the document does just go to show that
actually uh the economics of the deal
and maybe the partnership is putting as
a priority above the planet uh and
actually the agreements that are already
in in place so um it doesn't come as a
surprise and once again it is incredibly
infuriating and disheartening
um just to see these kind of uh memos
whatever they are being passed around if
there's nothing to to show me that they
are taking these things seriously yeah
even though the government will say that
that it's not positive to say but but
Julia what about this issue that you
said about imports from countries that
have less stringent environmental
standards is there some way around that
is there some way that this country can
put some kind of carbon tariff on any of
those Imports so that
companies in this country that are
abiding by stricter rules don't lose out
well we know that that Europe has been
considering border tax adjustments so
for example if you're importing steel
from a country which is not
decarbonizing its power system so their
steel industry is getting cheaper
cheaper electricity or or still able to
use coal for example that steel gets a
gets um an additional tax put on it sort
of as it reaches the border so that it
competes on a Level Playing Field with
the costs that Industries in in Europe
or in a country like the UK are having
to Bear the costs of supporting the
decarbonization
and very quickly Cal of course just two
weeks till cop do you think this is a
distraction ahead of that
um I don't know if it's a distraction I
think it's actually quite uh as Julie
kind of said uh quite worrying because
there are there are promises and pledges
and commitments that get made uh at
places like cop uh and knowing that
these sort of letters are going around
governments and that maybe these
promises that feels like lip service are
just that it doesn't give me much faith
that the deals and commitments we might
hear come out of Copy in the next couple
of weeks are going to mean anything and
actually if you look at the Paris
climate agreement it's a case in point I
think all you have to do is dig a little
bit into the detail to realize not just
the UK but most countries aren't on
track to meet the goals that they have
supposedly committed to in a legally
binding way so when you look to see
where is the accountability
um it's just very frustrating and again
it just doesn't fill you with much faith
of what's going to come out of cop okay
let's move on to our second topic uh
shall we and uh Prince William has been
fairly withering in his criticism of
space tourism in an interview saying the
world's greatest mind should be focused
on fixing this planet rather than
further exploring base um has he got a
point Julia
I'm absolutely with Prince William on
this one I think he's absolutely right
the enormous amount of energy as we
heard earlier in the program and the
enormous amount of of carbon emissions
associated with that it takes to get
somebody into space just for a quick
look at the Earth from space and to feel
weightlessness I mean I think that's
that's really shocking and also the
amount of money that's being spent that
could be spent on helping us with the
transition to Net Zero or indeed helping
us with the The crucial restoration of
nature that we need to be doing here on
our planet stop looking at our planet
from apart far and start making our
planet better as Prince William has been
encouraging them to but Kel don't we
learn a lot about our own planet from
looking at it from afar I mean look at
what Tim Peake our very own astronaut
that said more than 50 percent of
climate data comes from space assets so
can't we learn about the the progress
that we're making as far as tackling
climate change goes from space
yeah I mean like there is there is a
slight argument for that I would agree I
think you know space exploration space
tourism are two very different things if
you go just from the tourist side of
things uh Julie is so right it makes
absolutely no sense and it's quite
insulting to be honest with you the
space exploration has definitely
afforded us um you know the chance to
look at research like this and has
definitely probably provided some form
of Technology but I think given now
where we're at we're at a very critical
point when it comes to trying to reverse
the effects of climate change and I
don't think the solutions are going to
be found out in space in fact the
solutions are right here on Earth and I
think we should be putting time and
energy into these now while we are at
this crucial point and maybe further
down the line it can be something that
can be Revisited but but for now it just
doesn't seem to make much sense and that
feels like more of a distraction to be
honest with you we're looking beyond the
planet rather than looking in as as
Julia also said that so how do you
redirect those funds towards
um more Earthbound priorities at Julia
what's your your tip
well well I would say there are some
crucial things as as Cal mentioned um to
do with space I mean the satellite
monitoring is going to be absolutely
critical for us
um to know whether we're losing more
rainforest whether the commitments
countries are making to um to planting
new forests in Woodland whether those
forests and Woodlands are being
maintained in healthy condition all of
those things are going to be helped by
satellite technology and satellite
monitoring so there's plenty that space
can do as Tim Peak has said to help us
so if you want to invest in space invest
in some of these things that are going
to help us with the transition with
monitoring the transition with helping
to determine whether carbon offsets are
actually real and are actually removing
CO2 from the environment
okay well it's a fascinating um
discussion Kel I'm afraid we're out of
time so we can't come back at you I know
you were worried about space junk as
well but we'll revisit that another time
uh Kel Spellman thanks very much indeed
thanks to to Julia King good to get your
thoughts tonight
so we're all out of time but do stay
tuned coming up next we've got Sky News
tonight for you and the government
promises more help for the NHS after
latest figures reveal Hospital waiting
lists have reached record highs all the
latest coming up next siblings
[Music]